turkey is headed to a runoff election on
May 28th
is
what happens in this election will have
enormous Stakes both for turkey and for
the rest of the world turkey is a member
of NATO a member of the G20 one of the
world's largest economies it's also a
country that has a central geopolitical
role in the Middle East and in the war
between Russia and Ukraine erdogan is
one of the only world leaders who speaks
regularly with Russia's President
Vladimir Putin making him an important
channel into the Kremlin
president erdogan is facing a number of
challenges to his re-election turkey has
been in a currency crisis over the last
two plus years in part due to his own
economic decisions in which he has
pressured the Central Bank into cutting
interest rates in spite of turkey's High
rate of inflation it's caused living
standards to unravel the rising cost of
food of housing of medicine has really
narrowed erdogan's power base and turned
some people who used to vote for him
against him
another challenge is the devastation
caused by the earthquakes That Shook
turkey and Syria in February it killed
more than 56 000 people
living in the earthquake zone said that
they were basically left alone and that
state institutions including the
Emergency Services the police in the
Army were slow to arrive leaving
thousands of people underneath the
rubble waiting to be rescued yes
on the other hand camalculus is the
long-serving leader of turkey's largest
opposition party the Republican people's
party if killer wins it would be a
historic victory for turkey's opposition
and it would really breathe life into
Democratic institutions here in Turkey
he's been a fixture in Turkish politics
for decades he has been leading the
Turkish opposition over the last decade
his profile as a kind of Elder Statesman
positions himself as anti-ardoan
he likes to say that he doesn't use
polarizing language at the same time
he's promising to accelerate turkey's
clamp down on immigrants promising to
push millions of Syrian and Afghan
refugees out of the country
over the last 20 years erdogan has made
himself into turkey's most powerful
leader in a century and if he's brought
down through Democratic means that could
Inspire hope that other countries could
do the same